[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre jeudi
dernier dans cette hémicycle votre
majorité minoritaire a bloqué le début
le débat sur la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés comme contre le
covid-19 ce débat était pourtant
important et attendu par des dizaines de
milliers de nos compatriotes soignants
pompiers membres de leurs familles et
patients ce débat est d'autant plus
légitime que la France est l'un des tous
premiers derniers pays en Europe en
avoir toujours pas réintégré les
soignants non vaccinés même la Grèce va
les réintégrer avant le 1er janvier 2023
la suspension de nos personnels de santé
devaient être temporaires pourtant vous
vous y opposez toujours alors que nous
vous proposions un protocole de
protection renforcée
près de 3000 infirmiers aide-soignant
des centaines de médecins pharmaciens
orthophonistes kiné sont suspendus
depuis plus d'un an sans salaire ni
indemnisation de chômage et pendant ce
temps-là les hôpitaux font face à un
manque criant de soignants des enfants
se retrouvent sans suivi les
établissements médico-sociaux font
également face à des difficultés
majeures du fait d'un masque d'un manque
d'effectifs cela accentue la quantité de
travail des soignants présents et cela
affaiblit la qualité de la prise en
charge et des soins prodigués madame la
Première ministre les députés
républicains n'acceptent pas la mise au
vent d'une partie de nos soignants au
moment où on a le plus besoin de c'est
pourquoi nous vous demandons de
réintégrer son délai tous les soignants
que nous avons applaudis durant des mois
à 20h